mr. Popper's Penguins stars Jim Carrey
and carla Gugino
oh it tells the story of a successful
businessman who has inherited six
penguins who basically ruined his life
until his family who has become
estranged and separated from him start
to like the Penguins thus becoming more
involved with him in his life and so
it's like a good thing but at the same
time it's bad for his business so lots
of comedy and all kinds of insane events
ensue because of that honestly the
trailers were just pretty bad and I was
sad because I loved Jim Carrey you know
I grew up with him in the 90s
liar liar Ace Ventura Dumb and Dumber
the mask so many hilarious movies on top
of that he's got a lot of really good
dramatic performances Eternal Sunshine
of the spotless mind The Truman Show
he's a really good actor and to be
honest this movie was actually a little
bit and I thought it would be Jim Carrey
is trying to get permission to buy this
restaurant owned by Angela Lansbury
that's right from the old show Murder
She Wrote who here remembers that and
it's funny because I was like hey Dad
Angela Lansbury was in that movie and my
dad who is 63 goes Angela Lansbury is
still alive looks like yeah she is the
things I enjoyed work with Jim Carrey he
was surprisingly good in this movie even
though it times need to do incredibly
childish sentimental humor it actually
seemed like Jim Carrey was really
putting his all into the role in regards
to comedy now here's the issue all of
the funny parts for me had nothing to do
with the Penguins the Penguins in this
movie and all the humor had surrounded
them is for like very very young
children and parents who like to see
their children laugh dumb stuff CGI
penguins flipping and running into each
other and just acting like humans and
doing things that would never happen
that kids are gonna love and laugh at
and the
people are gonna be like oh gosh all the
best humor in this movie comes from Jim
Carrey and his physical slapstick some
of his little lines he comes up with and
just the way he carries himself and the
stuff you know faces he made all that is
great Jim Carrey is still Jim Carrey
he's there and he is Jim Carrey he's
hilarious but unfortunately some of the
aspects of the movie surrounding him
just just weigh him down this is just
not the movie he should really be in
right now
very very childish and just sappy and
just didn't work for me but Jim Carrey
worked for me in this movie he was funny
one of the things I did notice though is
that it was kind of like the cliche Jim
Carrey plot as of late he is a
successful businessman with a family who
doesn't really like him anymore because
his business has kind of taken him away
from the family plus he did his Jim
Carrey word in verse Almighty he had
beat a beautiful and this one he has
yeahbsolutely he is funny in this movie
he is a funny guy Jim Carrey is
hilarious he hasn't lost that it's just
that he needs to find a comedy that is
smart and different and original and not
just stick with the stuff that he's been
doing he needs to he needs to change it
up you know do more stuff like Eternal
Sunshine The Truman Show I didn't see
how lovely Philip Morris but apparently
that was great
to be honest if you're not a super
tightwad don't walk into this movie
thinking you're gonna get some seriously
is mr. flowers penguins the stars Jim
Carrey he's got a whole bunch of CGI
penguin running around what are you
expecting go there and think oh I'll
have a couple chocolates and that's
exactly what I got I actually had
consistent laughs throughout most of the
film because I was not expecting some
some thing you know it was just mr.
Popper's Penguins with Jim Carrey I'm
sorry I'm branding all of a sudden but
it's just because people are was like I
hate this really it's stupid I'm like
wait you don't go to grown-ups expecting
some oscar-worthy thing you just go to
grumps to see how to sandler and laugh
at him cuz he's silly you go to mr.
promise penguin see Jim Carrey and laugh
at it because he's silly at the same
time I do recognize the flaws a fairly
promising start but as soon as the
Penguins get involved it just gets it
just goes downhill but it's it's a fun
movie you know you'll you'll have fun
with it if you just take something out
of your throat that's clogging it and
making you feel congested from
having any type of fun you know so
anyway mr. Pappas bangers I'm gonna give
it two and a half out of four stars